[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the president has
decided that the Republican Congress
during its final weeks in office should
fund a wall along our southern border
with Mexico that's not a new idea
obviously Trump ran for office beginning
three years ago on that very promise
voters agreed with it they elected him
now he's demanding unequivocally that
the wall finally get built now at the
same time and this is not a coincidence
the American news media has identified
the single most racist idea that anyone
in the history this country has ever
come up with and that is of course
building a wall along our southern
border with Mexico watch the president
went to the heart of what I call his
Brown Menace theory these migrants
they're dirty people they bring disease
this border wall thing is about
controlling the Browning of America
Donald Trump is fixated on the southern
border as he was the day that he
announced this campaign it is not about
securing the borders it is about
xenophobic racist bigoted beliefs well
so that couldn't be clear border walls
are racist
we know that unlike border fences border
fences are not racist they're much
easier to climb over and that's why
Democrats have repeatedly voted to fund
them you could have lots of border
fences and still wind up with 22 million
illegal aliens living in your country we
have proved that conclusively over the
years fences are the perfect solution if
you're trying to pretend that you care
about border security while
simultaneously encouraging much of the
third world to move here without
permission fences are awesome for that
yay fences but walls well as Nancy
Pelosi has explained walls are immoral
according to CNN in fact walls are
nothing less than an attack on the human
heart listen and learn and a wall won't
solve it all that he's doing is putting
up walls around people's heart and we
are not a wall away from being better
don't waste billions of dollars of
taxpayer money in order to build
something that will not make our border
more secure yeah and that's the other
point they keep making
walls don't work they're totally
ineffective except in prisons and the
Vatican and outside Barack Obama's house
here in Washington and in almost every
upper income neighborhood in America
where walls surround the front lawns of
the homes where Hillary Clinton and beta
Arora called their fundraisers but long
international borders walls are useless
a borough would simply create a thriving
new market in taller ladders Jeb Bush is
to say that all the time
everyone in power agrees with them
they're knotting vigorously from their
gated communities we need border
security the wall is a part of border
security you can't have very good border
security without the wall no owner I
respond the experts say you can do
border security without a wall which is
wasteful and doesn't solve the problem
it's wasteful walls won't solve the
problem all the experts agree on that
and they have briefed Chuck Schumer and
he's passing on the news to us